The City of London is a unique place -- it's
the city in a city (in a country in a country)
that runs its government with perhaps the
most complicated elections in the world involving
medieval guilds, modern corporations, mandatory
titles and fancy hats, all of which are connected
in this horrifying org chart.
Why so complicated?
Though the new Skyscrapers might make you
think the City of London is relatively young,
it's actually the oldest continuous government
on the Island of Great Britain.
The City of London predates the Empire that
Victoria ruled, the Kingdoms Anne united and
the Magna Carta that John, reluctantly, signed.
While the London which surrounds the city
only got to electing its first Mayor in 2000,
the list of Mayors who've governed the City
of London is almost 700 people long going
back more than a thousand years.
The City of London's government is so old
there's no surviving record of when it was
born -- there are only documents, like the
Magna Carta, which mention the pre-existing
powers the City of London already had at that
time.
While a government like the United States's
officially gets its power from the people,
and Parliament gets its power from the Crown,
(which in turn gets it from God), the City
of London gets its power from 'time immemorial'
meaning that the City is so old, it just is.
And that age brings with it unusual and complicated
traditions, the most notable of these, perhaps,
is that in city of London elections, companies
get votes.
Quite a lot actually, about 3/4th of the votes
cast in City elections are from companies
with the remaining 1/4th from residents.
The way it works is that the bigger a company
is the more votes it gets from the City of
London.
The companies then give their votes to select
employees who work, but do not live, within
the city and it's these employees who do the
actual voting at election time.
The result is that the Common Council, the
bureaucratic beating heart of the City of
London, has about 20 common councilors elected
by residents of the city and about 80 elected
by companies of the city.
The reasoning behind this unusual tradition
is that for every 1 person who lives in the
City of London, 43 people commute in every
day.
In total that's 300,000 commuters using City
services and whose employment depends on the
City of London being business friendly.
The man in charge of the common council and
who heads The City's government is The Right
Honorable, the Lord Mayor of London.
Now, suppose *you* want to be Lord Mayor,
Surely, just as in that other London all you'll
need do is
a) Be a British, Commonwealth, or EU citizen,
who has
b) lived in the city for a year, and who
c) wins the election
Right?
No, in The City of London, that's not nearly
enough.
Ready for the qualifications list?
Before you even run for Lord Mayor you need
have been a Sheriff of The City of London.
But before you can be Sheriff, you need to
be an Aldermen.
What's an Aldermen?
Well, the City of London is divided into 25
wards, and each Ward elects one Aldermen to
represent it on the Court of Aldermen -- a
sub-section of the common council.
Before you can run for Alderman, you need
to gain Freeman Status... and who gives out
freeman status?
Why none other than the very Court of Aldermen
you're trying to get elected to.
Which might just seem like a conflict of interest.
Luckily there is another way to get the freeman
status -- join one of the City's Guilds -- sadly,
they aren't called guilds, they're called
Livery Companies (a name which is both more
boring and less descriptive), but the remnants
of medieval guilds many of them are and within
the City there are 108 of them to choose from
including, but not limited to,
The Apothecaries
The Fishmongers
The Masons
The Mercers
The Scientific Instrument Makers
The Bankers
The Shipwrights
The Wheelwrights
The Butchers,
The bakers,
*Two* different candlestick makers,
and the most exciting of all: The Chartered
Accountants!
Many of these guilds, like the Fletchers,
have become charities, but some are still
active, such as the Goldsmiths who test the
quality of British coinage and the Hackney
carriage drivers who license taxi drivers.
To join one of these guilds you'll either
need to meet the professional requirements,
or for the charities like the Haberdashers
you'll need the approval of two existing members,
others won't tell you how to become a members.
If, you meet none of the Livery Companies
membership requirements, but you think you'll
be a clever clogs and start your *own* Livery
Company and grant *yourself* freeman status,
tough luck because new Livery Companies need
to be approved by, you guessed it, the Court
of Aldermen.
But let's assume one way or another you get
the official freeman status certificate, now
you can finally run for Aldermen of a Ward
-- after the Lord Chancellor’s Advisory
Committee also approves of you.
But, that small barrier passed, you can win
election as Aldermen in either one of the
4 wards where people live or the 21 wards
where companies live.
Once on the court of aldermen to continue
your path to the Mayor's Office in Guildhall,
you must now be elected as sheriff, but this
time it's the members of the Livery Companies
who pick the sheriffs.
So *if* the Livery Company members elect you
as Sheriff, *after* you have successfully
completed your term *then* you can finally
run for Mayor.
But, surprisingly the, residents of the City
of London don't vote for the Mayor, our old
friends on the Court of Aldermen do.
So in summary, once you get freeman status
from either the court of aldermen or the livery
companies and after your ward elected you
as alderman and then the livery companies
elect you as sheriff and after your term as
sheriff ends but while you're still on the
court of aldermen then you can run for Mayor.
And -- assuming the other aldermen select
you, finally take your place as **The Right
Honorable, The Lord Mayor of London** -- for
one year, with no salary.
And you have to cover your own expenses, which
will be quite considerable as your new job
consists mostly of making hundreds of speeches
a year around the world promoting city business.
But you do get that fancy hat, which just
might make it all worth while.